intentionally narrow the phone
of my paper
find the geopolitical definition because
I want to send a certain message and I
think you know at least raise a few
questions for for discussion later so
that that's my intention but before I do
that I'd like to bring your attention to
they how do I get back okay I glad to
bring you your attention to the Chinese
characters behind my name here
movin long in Chinese William long I
went though pointed out because I want
to point out that I'm not anti Johnny's
joke now the other things that you see
most Vietnamese when they hear my name
they said oh the everlasting dragon you
know without knowing that of course is
true that 99% of the Vietnamese name
long mr. dragon but whenever whenever it
goes have been there it means forever or
I say perpetually distinguished
perpetually majestic or dignified and
you can see that really and even Chinese
even when they hear the world alone it's
all Dragon but you know I said no no no
moon alone and say who's she alone come
along with you one of the Chinese
Empress oh I think I just it's a joke
here but I do want to show that okay so
let me know how do I go to that okay
next
somebody can I do the big thing on the
other things that I can expand it to
full moon
No
okay now this presentation will examine
Vietnam's geopolitical position simply
on account of its geographical proximity
and political pops imitative China in
terms of geographical proximity on the
geographical from Vietnam proximity to
China has created great pressures on
Vietnam not only along Viet Nam's border
with China but also along Viet Nam's
western borders as well as from the air
and from space
now pressures from the northern border
include military pressures and also
security pressures commercial and trade
pressures pressures from the western
borders include the Mekong River Mencia
pressures from the northern border from
the western borders include Mekong River
dams project in China proper and allows
indirect pressures to Cambodia and Laos
pressure from the air and from space
include control of airspace and possible
air attacks from China freedom control
and attacks of Vietnam cyberspace and I
would like to make a quick comment here
I have talked with many high-level
Vietnamese officials and I entrusted to
me that China infiltration of the Viet
Nam's cyberspace had become so serious
that though many his years ago when I
talk with people is that whenever we had
something important to top of each
people with each other who had to write
on papers you know so that was the
extent of the of the
in Russia not the end result I shouldn't
say the angry zone but the result is
that by the by the late 1980s and early
1990s Vietnam was already very close to
China politically and hence has
increasingly succumbed to China's
pressure on a wide variety of areas one
body trade has increased exponentially
but largely to the detriment of local
Vietnamese production and business
enterprises Vietnam trade the first
deficit to China in 19 in 2015 for
example was over 32 billion u.s. dollars
or 1/5 of the atom's GDP this is not
taken into account illicit border trade
or smuggling partly as a resume of cheap
imports from China every year in the
last few years several hundred thousand
Vietnamese Hmong medium business
enterprises of gun bang bang crowd
Chinese investment it is difficult to
gauge the true extent of China's
investment in Vietnam partly because
Chinese enterprises have been largely
fronted by local Vietnamese and to joint
ventures with business enterprises from
other countries in the region case in
point is of foremost male still still
male in Latin which has been accused or
suspected for having caused massive
death fish along the coastal areas of
central Vietnam and those of you who
have retinol and in the press have seen
that you know it has now affected about
15 million people along the coastal area
and is spreading you know I mean South
North
anyway this Formosa Company has been
identified in the Western press as
Taiwanese but the reality is that it's a
joint venture between the Taiwan
company and a Chinese company and this
Chinese company mainland Chinese company
has contacts with high levels leaders in
the Chinese government anyway besides
that fact you know the company employs
over 10,000 workers from China proper
itself this company has a 70 year LAN
list at extremely low favorable prices
other long-term leases are in what with
the Miss experts have considered
sensitive subject areas and mentioned
the only two examples one is forest land
in many northern provinces and wishful
resorts in Danone these areas are
practically extraterritorial property of
China recently when you have a formosa
incident of formosa the leaders in
vietnam said we have no right to get in
there and to the company to investigate
you know because we have treaties with
china and the same thing happened before
in the beach resorts and dannan the
Chinese or some Chinese who kill each
with weapons so the Vietnamese wanted to
go or thora days want to go over there
to investigate and they were not allowed
to and later on was found out that this
was prostitution places and then also
games and weapons and so on and so on
and the vietnamese authorities at least
provincial authorities have not been
able to investigate these areas of
property now let me talk about Langley's
in lansing province bordering china we
serve as a battleground for the bloody
Chinese attack in 1979 in 2010 it was
reported by the Vietnamese press there
are some 60,000 out of 400 thousand
hectares almost 16% of forest land was
for 50 years the in love green company
of China and close to 10,000 hectare
though champion lodges of Taiwan at the
cost of less than the purchasing price
of a kilogram of vegetables or 20 US
cents per square meter of land and and
this company is used for planting you
can opt eucalyptus acacia local people
organize themselves to stop the
preparation for for other land because
you know they had been using this land
for their for their for planting trees
and for raising cattle and of course you
see it ended up in repression by now the
leasing of length of foreign companies
mainly to Chinese own in no green all
over the country created an uproar the
reported amounts leaves with 300,000
hectares affords first land in ten
provinces bordering China and Laos to
Hong Kong Taiwan and China 87% of which
was to the later countries are China
itself angry with the government and for
the first time ever in the meeting of a
National Assembly which is utilized in
luckily Congress here on June 11 2010
the chief of the National Defense
Committee accused the government for
underreporting the magnitude of a
problem
his committees investigation has shown
that a leasing occurred at 18 provinces
encompassing over 400 thousand hectares
of forest land before that retired
general Lieutenant General dancing when
a former Deputy Prime Minister and
former member of the
Bureau of the Vietnamese Communist Party
and one who used to supervise the
planting of forests issue a public
letter with another general questioning
the program on account of both national
security and the possible destruction of
natural natural forests designated for
environmental protection purposes now
let me talk about contractual work
convection work according to official
figures the official factors more than
90 percent of infrastructures
infrastructure mining and construction
projects in Vietnam have been given to
Chinese enterprises partly because of
favorable treatment given by the central
government as a result of political
pressures and partly through low
bungling and bribes but the real but the
real impacts have been environmental
damages as well as too late an
unfinished work examples include
unfinished and shut the street project
in Ho Chi Minh City and the many of you
who went to Vietnam a few years ago can
see that they were kind of you know
blocks right in the middle of of you
know how they say cross thinking
whatever and most of them work we belong
to two chinese contractors and
subcontractors the same thing happened
in hanoi in many other cities a visible
case that you cannot now see that has
caused a lot of complaining vietnam is
the unfinished rail road a railway or
metro project in Hanoi and the Chinese
company that had a contract said it ran
out of money so it can continue forcing
the government to have to give it more
money before it can you know begin begin
work again now the situation of unfair
and sloppy contractual works by Chinese
companies had become so serious
that when general sectarian Fulton
visited China in April 6 to 10 2015 he
pleaded with Xi Jinping publicly and and
this was the first order of the day to
intervene so as to preserve the good
relationship between the two countries
this led to much ridicule but back in
Vietnam my take on it is this William
Fulton was complaining he was reading
reading the riot act so to speak
xi Jinping say hey you know with I think
well I thought that we have bad days but
if you keep on treating me like this you
make my my position impossible and I'm
going to the United States very soon you
know I remember yelling sorry he went to
United States after that but I can't go
into that here now whatever you do is
you know with that very brief thing I
went to make some recommendations given
the geopolitical situation I just
mentioned one could perhaps understand
why vietnamese authorities have largely
been at sea so to speak joking again in
terms of dealing with china's assertive
if not outright aggressive activities in
the South China Sea after China used
force to take over the entire Paracel
archipelago in nineteen forty seventy
four as well as the submerged reefs
belonging to Vietnam in the Spratly
archipelago in 1988 killing many
Vietnamese defenders in the process I
did not want to delve into China's
activities here what I want to point out
is the fact that the restraint if not to
say timidity
by Vietnamese part
state in its responses to China's
activities has caused many of its
citizens to come into passion its
legitimacy bye-bye it's delicious
I mean legitimacy of the Vietnamese for
the state some of these two teammate
responses have been unnecessary if not
it's a ridiculous I just want to mention
three examples that will illustrate my
point
the first is the mixed reaction to the
1997 conference on the South China Sea
and the corresponding security situation
in South Asia organized by the group of
overseas Vietnamese scholars in New York
City this book actually involved
Vietnamese scholars and researchers in
Japan in seven countries in Europe and
also in United States I give some detail
about that event shortly now second the
official reference by Vietnamese
officials to Vietnamese attack will miss
both attack and self by Chinese ships
you've euphemistically as by caught and
called strange boat for table whereas
many Vietnamese have referred to them as
battle literally meant three boats or
the traditional colloquial for Chinese
of China and you can see there is a
conflict here between ordinary
Vietnamese again that I'm going to call
China by name but a tough battle which
is a local Vietnamese term to contradict
the table yeah tone but by the state is
a very interesting question yeah but
anyway I want to mention a third thing
the frequent use of force to disperse
demonstrations by Vietnamese citizens to
protest
attacks by the strange boats mention
and other provocations by China in the
South China Sea and that has also caused
a lot of friction between ordinary
Vietnamese citizens and the state now
let me go back to the the first thing a
topic about in 1997 the group of
Vietnamese scholars that included dr.
Wong here sitting in the back there
and myself we saw problems arising about
the South China Sea in connection with
the geopolitical situation in South Asia
and East Asia so we organized a
conference in New York and when you
organized the conference New York many
of the papers were circulated or sent to
the Vietnamese government first so the
Prime Minister office in Vietnam saw
that it was an important project and the
Prime Minister office sent two
representatives to the conference there
were formal officials you know just so
that to tone down the situation but one
was a high official form or fashion in
the ministry foreign ministry and the
other one was the former head of the
border office or Department you know
yeah overseeing on the borders
you know Vietnam so the premise of Prime
Minister office took this very very
seriously after a number of papers I
still you know quite important there
were two papers on legal matters one of
Russia's by by a lady
and I think you know Leo scholars you
know I can still benefit from from her
work but there was another one anyway so
so after the the the conference the
Prime Minister office and the political
how do you say that semantics what yeah
the national political publisher of
Vietnam was peggy know which is a very
famous still very much a publisher
wanted to publish our team it took us
two years to negotiate with the
authorities and people in vietnam over
almost every sentence what do in what to
include and what not to include and so
they were quotations from western
sources what we translated literally and
they wanted these quotations to be you
know admitted or they just try to read
translated wrongly
I mean at that time I was in Vietnam for
a year I taught at a national university
in Hanoi University so I go she ate it
with these people for our other
contributors so finally the book was
published and the director of an of the
national of the soup man kinkakuji I was
together when we went to Mesa
okay finally we happened then a few days
later I said well so I will tell you
what the problem euro has order all the
copies to be both so I said what you
know the Prime Minister office the Prime
Minister himself you know negotiated
this thing and and now you burn it what
are you doing so I told the director
of the publishing house and also the
aides of Prime Minister family to appeal
to the Politburo and after several
months the problem came back and say
okay the compromises we just take off
all the covers and then you have to put
a new cover on that and so this is a new
cover a new a new government's
proceedings of a conference on regional
development in the asia-pacific region
and disputes in the South China Sea
so that's okay he's no and then under
here it's a yeah right here it says for
for circulation you know for yeah within
you know the government only basically
that's what it means
so the director of the publishing house
I was going to back here and it's a okay
so now with this compromise you you can
take a 100 copies of office thing back
to your friends so each of you may have
total copies of or whatever
what but no no no so so that's what
happened then you say he packed this up
he personally delivered it to my my
house my apartment anyway then a couple
of days later the order was that I could
only bring out ten couplings I said are
you kidding me we are the authors of
this thing and you but that was the
extent of you know timidity I would say
you know yeah and I as I said a while
ago there was no reason for that kind of
thing especially with something that or
they had permission so what I want to
say is this one could perhaps
rationalized the rest this restraint on
the part of the villain is government
tower china if there has been some
reciprocal or something you know acts
from Chinese political leaders on the
country China has increasingly stepped
up its harms and not chance offensives
thought Vietnam and to a lesser extent
on toward other countries in the region
the situation has now reached a boiling
point not only in the South China Sea
but also inside Vietnam itself
threatening the welfare of Viet Nam's
inhabitants as well as the political
stability of the country perhaps even
the recent date of the party state
itself in face of the present
predicament it is necessary for the
Vietnamese government to take proactive
steps to regain the confidence of its
citizens and to rally the support of the
international community and the efforts
to bring about a peaceful resolution to
the crisis in the South China Sea as
well as political crisis in the Nam
these steps include the I just make a
few points
different things very very quickly one
make a public challenge to China to
agree
along with Vietnam to bring the disputes
in the South China Sea to the
International Court of Justice the
intense international code of laws of
the sea the Court of Arbitration
established according to appendix 7 of
the United Nations Convention on level c
and the special court established
according to appendix 8 to bring China
to the international internet
international court of public opinion
through exposure of China's persistently
fusion refusal to live up to its own
promises as well as as its unwillingness
to abide by international laws and by
its by the stipulation of the treaties
that China is a party off to my active
appeals to neighboring countries on the
need for bringing about a peaceful
resolution for the sake of stability and
development in the region in the case of
men love laws for example and in harmony
I can deal with
I have suggestion for every country but
I don't want to do in very I don't have
time but in the case of plane lock two
hours for example Vietnam offered to
provide easy access to the South China
Sea with a system of roads leading to
Danone and other port areas and this
also lessen China allows the reliance on
the dams you know invested my Chinese
function for provide outside countries
our second is the system term used by
China by also countries such as the
United States reasons that I could use
to really their citizens support for the
presence in the region and the
commitment to accountable to peace
stability and prosperity in the region
Viet Nam's do
graphic composition in South Asia with
its midday to China and its long
coastline covering most of the western
part of the South China Sea should give
Vietnam the advantage and moral
authority to speak up and reach out to
other countries with regards to the
United States just one it is
understandable that many Vietnamese have
been leery about America's long term
commitment to small countries in Asia in
this Asia giving me the many times that
they have fallen victims to us big power
politics but they should also understand
that America's long term power depends
on its commitment to freedom of
navigation and naval supremacy which
ultimately rests on trust by other
countries and last not least the above
ends the Vietnamese government should
allow Vietnam scholars and citizens to
make their views known to the world
without impediment otherwise the current
repressed dissatisfaction will probably
result in either impulsion or
explosion or both with far-reaching
consequences not only to Vietnam itself
but perhaps also to many other countries
thank you very much
you